alors on a on vous a quand même posé
quelques questions en amont tout à fait
pour que vous ayez le temps avec témoin
de vous préparer un petit peu ça va
intéresser tes spectateurs et puis après
j'aimerais aussi encore aussi peut-être
quelques petites interviews ben toi non
mais Benoît qui me dit qu'il sort de son
corps euh moi justement je voudrais en
parler de Benoît parce que avant
l'émission notamment à Victoria parce
que euh
non mais c'est surtout que en fait je ne
suis pas étonné de ce que vous avez dit
d'ailleurs dans ce que j'ai marqué sur
vous c'est à peu près ça c'est-à-dire
que vous vous avez vraiment une énergie
particulière et hors de tous les
chroniqueurs il y en a quelques-uns qui
ont vraiment une belle énergie ou une
force ou une protection mais alors vous
vous êtes vraiment à part ah oui
c'est-à-dire vous voyez une carrière
alors au-delà de ça c'est à dire que
déjà de toute façon c'est un garçon qui
va vraiment réussir mais c'est pas que
ça c'est à dire que vous êtes hyper
ultra protégé j'ai rarement vu ça non
mais vraiment
ah ouais
bah dis donc ah on est vraiment vraiment
parce qu'on précise aussi pardon qu'on a
donné c'est vrai que j'aurais dû on a
donné votre nom à chacun et puis après
bah vous nous avez dit pardon j'ai
oublié votre nom Carole nous a dit je
parlerai de ceux qui me semblent le plus
de choses à dire effectivement bah du
coup de l'autre et pas dedans toi tu as
une superbe comme j'ai de la lumière
voilà c'est fait on a passé un quart
d'heure de si non plus il va y avoir euh
très très gros bouleversement votre vie
donc très peu de temps et c'est quelque
chose vraiment d'inatoires
qui va venir à vous et vous allez
apparemment accepter cette opportunité
et à partir de là vous allez décoller
mais c'est très intéressant
tout ce que vous allez faire vous allez
le réussir ah merci on va parler des
people on va parler des people mais
quant à toi ça fait 12 ans que je te
porte que tu me rapporte rien si ça
marche tu auras intérêt un petit peu en
oseille alors vous a posé des questions
sur la famille royale selon vous une
réconciliation est possible entre les
membres de la famille royale oui non
alors
au niveau des de Harry et donc son frère
William oui il va y avoir une
réconciliation mais plus une
réconciliation liée évidemment
oui à la fonction mais peut-être pas on
va dire un lien qui va s'établir de
manière
à peu près ça va ça va pas s'éclater
très bien non très très bien attention
là on va sur les sujets de fond les amis
Céline Dion battle revenir
pardon mais j'y crois pas hein
c'est mon Oracle qui m'a dit mais moi
j'y crois pas
elle revient pas à son retour à son
retour son oracle ne crois pas à son
retour tout ça mais il y a pas le
Compass au retour moi je crois pas à son
retour je crois d'ailleurs que elle
était encore malheureusement faible et
fragile et elle aura une proposition
avec un médecin d'ici l'année prochaine
qui est un chercheur ou quelqu'un qui a
une relation avec la recherche puisque
apparemment ce qu'elle a est en relation
directe avec sa génétique alors on va
pas trop long plus c'est médical alors
juste alors un qui malheureusement va
très très bien et très très fort lui
arrive jamais rien Cyril Hanouna il a
signé pour 4 ans à quel moment il
comprend qu'on peut pas être le Damien
Thévenot de Cyril Hanouna toute notre
vie alors est-ce qu'il y en a des bonnes
nouvelles il va continuer à réussir
il va peut-être même avoir un autre
enfant d'ici trois ans mon Dieu je suis
enceinte oui voilà c'est ça Mathieu
il va avoir un enfant je pense qu'il y a
peut-être quelque chose à faire entre
vous pour avoir un enfant oui
parce que
je suis très embêtant que cette émission
vous pensez que Cyril et j'aime la vie
comme on dit je pense je pense que si
vous vous l'invitez
je suis complètement complètement perdu
Miss France qui va être Miss France oh
je sais pas quoi en plus j'y connais
rien je sais même pas qui se présente je
peux pas vous répondre la guerre très
importante ça c'est un sujet moins drôle
la guerre est-ce que oui ou non Irène
une guerre il y a un truc que je
comprends pas vous dites je n'y connais
rien mais la voyance on vous demande pas
de connaitre exactement les les photos
quand même
la région
ou que je ne vois pas je dis je ne vois
pas là vous voyez la guerre je ne vois
pas tout le temps hein de toute façon et
comme je ne vois pas je ne vois la
guerre la guerre alors la guerre la
guerre alors on y va alors
là Mathieu qu'est-ce que vous entendez
par guerre parce que la France va
rentrer va rentrer en guerre écoutez moi
je ne le sens pas comme ça en revanche
je pense évidemment et ça là monsieur va
me tacler en disant oui mais ça c'est
une évidence et vous aurez peut-être
raison mais en tout cas malgré certaines
restrictions ben on va quand même
continuer à essayer de garder une forme
d'équilibre même si il y aura forcément
d'accord mais le risque de Claire dont
on parlait on va pas l'avoir on va pas
se prendre une bombe nucléaire toute
façon même sur le on se la prend
voilà c'est ça vous ne serez pas là pour
me taquet dernière question très
importante parce qu'il y a des rumeurs
et là Monsieur en plus il connaît bien
Brigitte et Emmanuel Macron vont-ils
divorcer avant la fin du monde alors
divorcé non mais par contre il y a
forcément une séparation qui va arriver
avec Cyril et lui divorce de Brigitte
pour moi oui attendez où est-ce que je
l'ai mis parce que j'en ai tellement
qu'au final je ne sais plus et ben les
amis c'est pas la peine vous en avez
assez dit on y croit on y croit pas on
est de la France ce soir en direct dans
cette émission Brigitte Macron et
Emmanuel Macron se sépare dans très peu
de temps cette étape spéciale tout de
suite c'est pas